this is the new Apple iPhone 6s and 6s
plus and let me cut right to the chase
should you buy one probably eight years
since it debuted I still think the
iPhone is the best smartphone you can
buy Android phones have made some
tremendous improvements and Apple's
definitely had some missteps along the
way but the way Apple is able to both
develop the hardware and the software
together still makes for the best user
experience these new S models are
typical of the usual two year iPhone
product cycle nothing looks terribly
different on the outside but a lot
changed inside let's start with the
display Apple's added another dimension
to multi-touch and called it fittingly
3d touch basically if you press harder
than normal you can pull up shortcuts
for different apps it's a little bit
like right click on your mouse a couple
of things about this though first 3d
touch does take a little getting used to
push the wrong way and you just wind up
getting all your apps to do that
jiggling thing when you want to move
them around the screen then there's the
matter of what you can do with 3d touch
right now things are a little bit
limited it's better sure that I can
preview a mail message in my inbox or
jump to a new note but other uses are
more questionable who exactly needs a
shortcut to call up a private browsing
page fortunately Apple's allowing
third-party developers to use the
technology so we may see more clever
applications in the future the other big
changes have to do with the successes
cameras the rear-facing one's been
upgraded to 12 megapixels and can now
shoot ultra high resolution 4k video it
can also take a new type of picture
called live photo which captures the
moments before and after the shutters
been released one thought about all
these live photos and 4k video they do
take up more room on your phone so if
you're in the Apple Store walk right
past that 16 gigabyte model and get an
iPhone with more storage the
front-facing camera can now take better
selfies thanks to a display that can act
like a flash it
even match the ambient color of the room
so you don't come out looking like a
zombie but what makes these new iPhones
the best smartphones you can buy are the
fundamentals the new a9 processor is
ludicrously fast as is the touch ID
sensor which now works instantly there's
also a raft of improvements thanks to
the successes new operating system iOS 9
you can now activate a battery saving
low-power mode get transit directions on
maps and find things faster thanks to an
improved search and Siri Wow new
features are what usually get the
headlines but it's these behind the
scenes upgrades that really matter
thanks to blindingly fast hardware and
well-designed software these new iPhones
actually begin to sort of fade away and
let you focus more on what you're doing
the best things about the new iPhone 6s
and 6s plus aren't all the new things
that grab your attention it's all the
stuff in the background that you never
notice